if you could pick one person to to be in
Biden's ear and one person to be in
Trump's ear who would that person be go
with me here who would that person be
and what would that message be to Trump
and to Biden in your opinion I I don't
know how effective he is today but I
think Biden could hear and get some
counsel from Jimmy Carter so I don't
think he's going to believe Clinton
whatever they say I don't even think
Democrats trust Clinton's I think they
always think there's a motive there I
think he will trust Jimmy Carter because
Jimmy Carter's got nothing to gain or
anything if he's still able to
communicate I think Carter would be
somebody good I don't even know if Obama
would be somebody good I don't think he
would sit there because Obama's always
got Obama's still young and ambitious so
he may give kisses his wife maybe I
think Biden's wife and be like I don't
like what Brock just said forget about
what he said I think if Jimmy said it I
think he may listen to Jimmy I don't
know again I'm just speculating I don't
know we're playing a game
I just had a very uh I had somebody over
at the house this weekend who was his
right hand guy at one point I'm not I'm
talking to somebody that was a former
mayor of a very big city the financial
capital of the world the American mayor
and we spend four or five hours together
this Saturday a lot of interesting
conversations together we didn't shoot a
video we didn't shoot us and nothing it
was just conversations we had together
um I I don't know I don't know because
what what Trump has going for himself is
60 years in business
so many people's lives you may have
changed that backstabbed you so many
people's Courier that there were
nobodies you gave them a shot they work
with you and they use that on their
resume to get the next job to become and
then they turned their backs on you and
they said something you saw the clip
you're like wait a minute did you forget
17 years ago you were crying in my
office those moments people remember
like I remember a guy named Michael him
off is crying 16 years ago we're in
Granada Hills and he says one day when I
make it I'm going to tell everybody you
changed my life I will never forget
these late night conversations till two
o'clock in the morning 10 years later he
backstabbed me and I'm like oh wow so if
I'm on like a this level of what I
experienced at 35 years old he did that
to me what makes you think what he's
gone through so I don't think he trusts
anybody I don't think he trusts anybody
I think the amount of people he trusts
is
is actually less than this well I think
so like if you think by the way by the
way let me put it to you this way let me
let me rephrase the statement trust and
respect not just trust trust I think he
trusts a lot of people okay
but trust and respect their opinion is I
think less than this I think there's one
person out there when you think deeply
about it it'll come there and I don't
think it's Don Jr and I don't think it's
Eric but there is one person out there I
think he really respects and he knows
has his absolute best in mind that's
Ivanka you think so yeah the
relationship with his daughter is the
strongest of any of his kids and she's
always strong strategically but then
stays out of the spotlight
um you say oh you know Jared wants this
so that well that's a power couple
there's some of that but I think he
would listen to his I think he would
listen to it okay let me ask you this
because if he he is running again
obviously yeah Don Jr is going to play a
major role so is Eric but Ivanka and
Jared for that Jared Kushner have
already come out and said we do we want
no part of round three we are at 2016
2020 took its toll on us we're building
a home in Miami you know I know about
that they they want no part of this what
what how much does that play a role in
your opinion
of not having her in his Corner this
time around I think that's that's big
and I think if you take a look at Trump
right now that there's like a little
he could use some firmness on the
Strategic Rudder I think he's the same
guy but I think he could use a little
firmness on the Strategic Rudder I don't
think he would have had a particular
dinner with a particular guest unless
things were that we all know about two
months ago before Kanye Nick Fuentes yep
I think things like that if he had a
stronger Rudder you know what I'm saying
like a core around him hey Dad I don't
know if this is the way to do this can
you pull up the Vegas odds real quick by
the way we're having this conversation
about the presidency
I mean dude Ivanka maybe she's just
being quiet she's like I'm not going to
talk about this maybe she's thinking
about the future I mean I mean maybe she
could run sometime down the road bro you
wouldn't see that I don't see that
Ivanka Trump let me just throw something
crazy out there there's rumors of a 1400
Adam uh yeah here you know well go ahead
go talk about well these are the odds
everyone knows here on the show I don't
look at Pew I don't look at Quinnipiac I
don't think ABC I don't look at Fox
Vegas polls the because they have money
on the line skin in the game they have
money to win or lose this is the numbers
I look at so Ron DeSantis the clear
favorite to be the president of 20 20 24
2024 Ron DeSantis plus 225 Trump at plus
350. Joe Biden slightly behind Trump at
plus 400 and then a steep cliff fall off
and then Look whose name is right there
you got Gavin Newsom kamalo I think has
no chance no meet Buddha judge Mike
Pence Nikki Haley Michelle Obama these
are all thousand two thousand three
thousand chances Glenn young and nobody
knows you The Rock's still somehow in
there and then you got just the fact
that Hillary Clinton's name is still in
there I'm telling you right now the
gambling bet not the sure bet I'm
talking about just the BET where because
y'all Democrats say what you want they
know how to they know how to win when it
comes on this because put your money on
Gavin I'm gonna say this right now I'm
not rooting for Newsom whatsoever I'm
not either but let's go put some money
awesome yeah we'll 500 each I'm done
scroll up by the way it's 1400. okay I
say you guys put 10 dozen eggs on that
there we go ten thousand dollars
by the way nowadays [ __ ] go to the
blackjack table all in matter of fact
be a do use your quick uh math break if
I put 10 grand on Jasmine Newsome right
now how much do I win
140 000 no 14 Grand you said 10.
so we put a Grant Pass so we put a g
we're gonna win 14. you know what that
is 140 Grand that's a down payment on
that Rolls-Royce
damn right yeah I mean it's actually not
a bad bet so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]